翻訳: Maki Sugimoto
校正: Hiroko Kawano
長年 外科医をやっていると
患者さんから学ぶことが沢山ある
っていうことに気付くんです
例えば 患者さんが
「私はがんで非常に苦しい」と
言ってくれた場合
我々は医者としてだけではなくて
人としても 対処しなければ
ならないのです
多くの患者さんは我々に
こんな素晴らしいことを
言ってくれます
「私たちの経験や医療の情報を
ぜひ他の患者さんにも役立ててくれ」と
よし わかった
でも残念ながら
その人のデータは その人のものでしかなく
他の患者さんに活用しづらいですよね
例えば皆さん 自分で
撮られた事のあるレントゲンや
採血のデータ 健康診断のデータは
誰かのために活用したことってありますか
なかなか ないんです
それは 個人情報だから他に配れないのと
さらに医療の技術や医者の知識が
「暗黙知」といって
文章やデータで伝えられるよりも
手の動きやベテランの知識で
伝わるようなものが多く
暗黙知のまま
伝わらないことが多いのです
最近 医療の技術がどんどん進み
レントゲン画像は３次元を
簡単に作れるようになりました
３Ｄ画像で臓器と臓器
癌や血管が
非常によくわかるように
なったのですが
残念ながらまだ
平面のモニターの中で
見ているに過ぎないんです
つまり見ている人は そこから動かず
本当の奥行きを
把握できないんですね
皆さんもスマホやタブレット
テレビや映画
四角い枠に捕らわれている
という不自然さに
意外と慣れてしまって
気付いていないんです
医療の技術はさらに「内視鏡手術」
という進化を遂げました
お腹を開けるのではなくて
カメラを入れて手術をするのですが
傷を小さくする
患者さんのメリットに反し
四角い平面のモニターで
限られた視野しか見られず
空間を認識するのが なかなか難しく
技術を向上したり
間違って誤認することを回避する
こういったものを妨げてしまうんです
そこで １つ素晴らしい
アイデアを思いつきました
臓器と臓器の形や関係だけ
データとして座標に抽出をすれば
手術の時に的確に
空間が分かるのではないか
コンピュータを使うと
患者さんの CT やレントゲンから
そこの臓器だけを正確に
抽出することができます
最近は人工知能や
ディープラーニングを使うと
自動で一つ一つの臓器のデータを
別々に抽出することが
できるようになりました
これをすべて座標のデータで
コンピュータで再現をすると ー
これを「ポリゴン」と言います ー
「ポリ」は「沢山」
「ゴン」は「角」
つまり多角形に変形できるんですね
このデータを変更することで
自然な立体視が
できるようになりました
バーチャルリアリティを
体験できるゴーグルを使って
右目と左目に立体的に表示をすると
被っている人には
脳の中で これが１つに
しかも自分の周りすべてを
囲むように体験ができるんです
もはや マウスやキーボードがいらず
自分が自然に歩くと
データが後ろに行ってくれる
つまりその空間の中に
自分が没入しているような体験が
できるようになりました
もちろん ただのCGではなくて
患者さんのデータ 一人一人から
これを人工知能やコンピュータで
簡単に作れるようになったのです
ただ地図を見るだけではなくて
患者さんのレントゲンの中に
手術の器具や
どこからアクセスをするか
こういった位置情報を統合することで
まさにカーナビゲーションのような機能を
果たすことができました
カーナビが作れるということは
自分の位置と相手の位置を
他の人にも知らせられるということです
ベテランのドクターは
どのように切っている
若手はどこが失敗しやすい
こういったことを
みんなで共通に把握することができ
合併症や手術時間を減らしたり
技術の向上を促進したり
することができます
さらに手術の方法を
一人一人 的確に計画するために
患者さんの情報の中に
その人に必要な医療器具を
その元のデザインのデータのまま
３次元で表示する機能も開発しました
そうすることで
例えば この背骨の手術の患者さんは
スクリューをどの角度で
どの深さで どの位置に入れれば
背骨が真っ直ぐになるか
こういったことを術前に計画しながら
その位置と位置を正確に
もう数ミリ単位で
計測をすることができます
これにより ベテランと若手が
どこが違うかという評価ができたり
若い人がどのぐらいで
上手くなったかという
「ラーニングカーブ」という技術の向上が
評価できるようになったのです
これを一般の人にも活用しようと
ある私の友人の大学教授が
声を掛けてくれました
彼は脳梗塞を患い
血管が詰まっていて
麻痺もあったのですが
なんとかリハビリでリカバーをしました
彼が自分の大学の授業で
生徒に生きた授業がしたいと
提案してくれました
彼の脳のMRIのデータを頂き
バーチャルリアリティにしました
本人が自分の脳の中に入る体験です
しかもこれは
生徒がみんな見ている授業です
彼は自分の脳の中に入り
脳の詰まった所を見つけると
一生懸命に擦りだしました
「この血栓のおかげで」
それを見ていた生徒たちは
「あっ怖い 血管
頑張ろう もうチョコレートとか止めよう」
というふうに気付くようになるわけですね
こういった本人が語ることというのは
本当に人に訴えかける
パワーがあると思います
この大学教授とは
非常に親交を深くして頂き
もっと多くの人に活用できるように
「HoloLens」という
もっともっと簡単に
それがホログラムのように
体験できるデバイスを
まだ日本で発売される前に
我々に貸して頂きました
そうしたところ
それに賛同したプログラマーから
一緒に会社を起こさないかと
声をかけていただき
実は起業をすることができたのです
そのニュースは実は
このHoloLensを開発している
Microsoftの本社まで話が行き
TEDトークにも登場しているスピーカー
アレックス・キップマンと
我々もこのHoloLensの医療活用について
模索することになりました
実際の外来で 患者さんの説明に
このHoloLensを使って
空中に患者さんのレントゲンを
３次元にしたものを
複数人で共有することで
癌の位置はどこから切るか
この人はどこが普通と違うか
といったことを
把握するようになりました
もちろん医師だけではなくて
看護師や他の技師さん
医療スタッフがみんなで共有をしたり
患者さんにも非常にわかりやすい
説明ができるようになりました
この方は子宮がんで
卵巣と子宮を３年前に
全摘出した女性です
３年前のデータから
バーチャルリアリティ
ホログラムを作り
本人が被る体験をしてもらいました
３年前の自分に対面した時
彼女は素晴らしいことを
２つ言いました
「私はもう悪いものから解放されているんだ
というのが分かった」
もう１つ「やっぱり私は女性だったんだ」
と言ってくれました
この体験をしていた時
彼女は思わず
自分の子宮に手を伸ばし
触ろうとしたんですね
もちろん触れないのですが
脳の中ではおそらく
それに触れる体験につながり
３年前の自分に
「よく頑張ったね」と声をかけたんです
もしかしたら我々は既に
タイムマシーンを
発明したのかもしれません
これを多くの子宮がん予備軍といわれる
若い女性たちに体験してもらい
子宮がんの早期発見や
予防に繋げる活動を
全国でしているわけです
もちろん日本に限らず
こういったデータは
日本語 英語 他の言語という
壁を乗り越えるんですね
そうしたところ
たまたま私の友人がこれを被り
「あ これは検診しなきゃいけない」と
認識を変え
検診を受けたところ
たまたま がん一歩手前という組織が
子宮から出ました
もちろん緊急手術です
幸いなことに 時間が間に合い
がんになる前にすべて取りきれ
再発の可能性はゼロだという
良い結果が現れたわけです
彼女はこの手術の前に言いました
「もしかしたらこのゴーグルを被らなかったら
危機感を感じなければ
検診も受けず がんになるのを
黙って待っていたかもしれません」と
これを多くの若い人の
例えば学校の授業とか
啓蒙活動にも
今 普及しているわけです
もちろん私の本業は外科医です
手術中や手術の前に
患者さんの情報を最終確認をし
手術室のテーブルの位置や
機械や人の位置を 瞬時にスキャンをして
この２つの座標を 合わせます
そうすると 患者さんの目の前に
その人の状況が再現できるんです
ベテランと若手が Wi-Fiで
位置を共有することで
同じ位置の把握ができるようになりました
手術の前もカンファレンスも直感的になり
手術の練習も
ただ模型を縫うのではなくて
実際の人の動きに合わせて
体で覚えることができました
また臓器の位置にぴったり位置を合わせると
まるでその臓器が透けているような
３D のプロジェクションマッピング
というのも可能になったんです
さらに どこから切ったら良いか
どこに穴を開けるか
正確にしなければいけないという情報まで
そこから提示できるようになりました
これはガイドですね
ナビゲーションの先に
「ガイド」という概念があります
そこに確実に導いてくれるということです
医師はこれを見ながら
医療器具を挿入し
正確で安全な手術が
できるようになったわけです
これをもちろん
健康な人にも活用したいと思い
妊婦さんの心のケアに使っています
例えば 妊娠中 本人が
自分のお腹を見ることで
赤ちゃんが元気なのがわかれば
うつの予防や愛着障害の予防に
つながるかもしれません
もちろん旦那さんにも
非常に有効なツールでした
２人で一緒に見たいと言っていたので
２人で見るようにしていたところ
私は凄いことに 気付きました
家族写真を撮ったんです
（笑）
おそらく生まれる前に
家族の絆というのを
初めて形にしたのではないでしょうか
この子供は無事に生まれ
より愛着が深くなったと言ってくれました
うちの父は90です
細かいことを言ってもわかりません
でも直感的に把握をすれば
家族が病気に向き合い
健康に語り合う時間を
コミュニケーションを作れるように
なるんではないでしょうか
暗黙知を構造化データにすることで
形式知に変えます
個人情報も汎用情報になるため
我々社会が医療を担えるようになる
そんな第一歩に つながると思うんです
それが皆さんの家庭の中で
もう既に始まっているんです
ぜひ そういった情報に触れる
今日はきっかけにして頂ければ
社会が医療を担う世の中が
作れると思います
ご静聴ありがとうございました
（拍手）